let's go next to our caller
from the 614 area code who's calling
today from 614.
hello yes that's you
oh hi um josephine is my name
oh you're calling you're calling from
it's country code 61.
it's co where are you calling yeah yeah
i'm coming from australia
um wow victoria yeah thank you for
taking my call i
i've tried a few times and i just
thought i just wanted to comment you
know
um this is great uh now
um yeah i have so i live in victoria
melbourne you know melbourne just out of
i do do you know your geography i'm sure
of course of course yeah
um i um i suppose um
yeah i could ask a lot of questions i
could i or
talk about a lot of things but i do have
a question for you and i don't want to
waste your time you've got
other callers beautiful but um yeah i
suppose
do you have any questions for me none
whatsoever no
no i mean we'll no here here's my
question this is good yeah i'll ask you
the
questions let me ask you the questions
uh is the united states a laughing stock
right now in australia oh cool yeah
yeah yeah i mean look i mean it
i i'm informed i lived in new york city
for 10 years
okay in london for three years so i've
and i have close fam
uh family and friends there so i'm
keeping up to date
via shows like yours and you know stuff
i can watch
without yeah you know
i i like to keep myself informed however
yeah unfortunately it is
i mean when i was you know there were
issues the healthcare system i mean the
um
yeah and uh i left just after
uh barack obama was
elected you know a really exciting time
and um
and uh yeah it is and to be quite honest
i'm
just waiting for this whole long
exhausting and torturous reality show to
be over
right i hope your last episode is in
november because and that there's not
another season
because it's it's that
some people might say okay well you're
not an american
okay nationalistic attitude things
we're a global society i mean 40 years
now and
i um it's been ramping up i can see
everything that's going on over the
world
mentally um it's it's
exhausting i mean i think once i saw
that um
in pennsylvania latrobe
yes uh don yeah but i watched it through
your show because i mean
you know it was sort of a buffer but i
mean i had to i couldn't find the remote
and i had to
unplug the television streaming through
my right i'm shocked you didn't throw
the tv
out the window altogether actually sorry
yeah i know some people reported
throwing the unplugging the tv wasn't
enough they had to throw the tv out the
window
yeah yeah yeah like i mean because if
you're streaming from your devices like
an ipad or something
it doesn't turn up and just ah no one
had to go outside
and then you know i decided that you've
got the post
post postal service which and then on on
the other side of the military
honestly really and i think to myself
i'm how can you do you want to get
voted out is that you what you want
surely not
right but like
criticizing the military these two
sacred
you know institutions and john mccain oh
um yes well listen you've hit all of the
important topics and uh
a number of different things there we uh
we we hope to
do uh well by the australian people in
november and to remove donald trump i
hope it happens and i hope to hear from
you again
yeah i've got one question for you oh
you do okay
okay why hasn't there been a trump gate
sorry what why what why hasn't there
been a
trump guide why hasn't why hasn't
something been called trump
i have no idea i'm not sure i i i will
make a phone call and try to find out
trump trump trump my trump guide trump
guide
watergate trumpcate no i understand i
understand yeah no i'm i don't know why
there's been nothing
there are too many there are too many of
them
right right okay
thank you so much for the call i do
appreciate it my pleasure no the
pleasure is all on this side of the
phone line hope to hear from you again